what could have been done
better in the way of handling the
original
no mask mask hoax no hoax chronovirus
slowdown
what could have been done better the
president told us
the president is on the wires today
he has a mask on he has said he's
tweeted it out himself with a picture of
a mask
it has come to my attention that if
there's not an opportunity to social
distance
if that's just not there then wearing a
mask is
the next best thing so i'm the biggest
patriot in the world
i'm putting on my mask you do too he
tweeted it out today
that should have been tweeted out on day
one that should have been where it
started
it it should have never been on day one
what is day one
well unfortunately medicine and science
don't behave the way we want them to if
his closest medical advisors
scientific advisors flipped the switch
for whatever reason
they felt like pp was available in
abundance for whatever reason if the
people
because you have to rely on experts
you're not you're president you're not
god so you you're allowed to rely on the
people you put around you
but the day that it was decided that
maybe masks are better
we're looking at other countries and
we're seeing their example they're
having an easier time closing down
they're having a much easier time much
more importantly reopening masks are
better the science was still on both
sides
but on that day had he gone with his
closest advisors
there would be millions of people who
would be able to keep their jobs
and it's as simple as that how much of
that is on him how much of that is on
fauci
well again he's found she did
terrible damage to to the cause of masks
coming flat out and saying that they
were not necessary
um when it was decided that that was a
mistake
it needs to have been sung from the
hills
this was a huge mistake on mar on my
part mia culpa
but please trump or fauci saucy okay
but please in all humility
please listen now please listen to me
now and you know what listen to my
equivalence around the world
listen to my equivalents in other
countries look at the examples of other
countries that are going to reopen
much better than we have germany take to
take but one example
don't listen to me if you don't if
you've lost confidence in me listen to
them
look at their example and then make the
decision
to not have it be a patchwork approach
from one state to the next look this is
still a baby virus
we are living under the assumption that
it is agnostic to heat
well i am sorry but it is 96 degrees and
they just raised the level in
brownsville texas to a level four
because their hospitals are overwhelmed
this virus doesn't give a damn about the
heat
maybe it's even angrier when you get to
the cold
we don't know until we get to the fall
but it's still a baby virus
but it's raged through much of the
country and
i don't look at this from a scientific
perspective and that is what gets
oh i don't know 99 of my twitter
followers so angry i don't
i won't look at this from a scientific
perspective because
i'm not a medical doctor i'm not an
epidemiologist and i never will be
what i know is that the media is
a source of dissension in america and
divisiveness
[Music]